So, nine different categories. Could you
tell us which are the most important of
all the voluntary fasts?
The most important of all the voluntary
fast is fasting
in the month of Muharram, especially the
Ashura, that is the 10th day of
Muharram.
And our beloved Prophet Muhammad S.A.W.
said,
it's mentioned in Hadith of Sahih
Muslim,
volume number two, in the book of
fasting, Hadith number 2612,
where a person asked the Prophet that
which is the most important
of
the prayers after the prescribed
prayers, after the fardh prayers. And
which is the most important fast after
the fardh fast, after the fast in the
month of Ramadan?
Prophet replied, the most important
prayer
after the fardh prayers
is the prayer at night.
And the most important fast after the
fast in Ramadan is fasting in Muharram.
Fasting in the month of Muharram is the
most important. And our beloved Prophet
Muhammad S.A.W. further said, it's
mentioned in the Hadith of Tirmidhi,
in the book of fasting, Hadith number
752,
the beloved Prophet said
that whoever fasts on the day of Ashura,
it is expiation of his sins
for the previous years.
The all the sins that he did in the
previous year, it will be expiated.
Another Hadith
of Sahih Bukhari,
volume number three,
in the book of fasting,
Hadith number 2004, it says that Ibn
Abbas, may Allah be pleased with him, he
says that Prophet Muhammad S.A.W.
when
he reached Medina,
he asked the Jews
who used to fast
on the 10th day of
Muharram,
that "Why do you fast on the 10th day of
Muharram?"
So, they replied that the Bani Israel
got the freedom from the enemies, and
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala gave them
freedom on this day. And Prophet Moses,
peace be upon him, he fasted on this
day.
So, Prophet Muhammad S.A.W. replied that
we have more right over Prophet Moses,
peace be upon him, than you do. And he
commanded the Muslims that they should
fast on the 10th of Muharram, that is
Ashura.
There's another Hadith in
Sunan Abu Dawud, volume number two, in
the book of fasting, Hadith number 2439,
where
Ibn Abbas says, may Allah be pleased
with him,
that
when Prophet Muhammad S.A.W. said that
the Muslims should fast
on the 10th of Muharram, on the day of
Ashura, some of the Sahaba, some of the
companions of the Prophet, came and told
him that this is the day
which is celebrated
by the Jews.
It's an important day for them.
Prophet said, "Next year, inshallah,
we'll also fast on the 9th."
But unfortunately, Prophet did not live
to see the next year. He expired before
that.
It's mentioned in Sunan An-Nasa'i,
book of fasting, Hadith number 2416,
that
the Prophet did not miss
four things.
Number one is fasting on the day of
Ashura.
Number two, fasting the first 10 days of
Dhul-Hijjah.
Number three, fasting three days every
month, the Ayyam-ul-Beed. And praying
the
Sunnah salah before the Fajr salah.
So, based on this, we come to know
that
it's very good to fast on Ashura,
that is the 10th day of Muharram. But to
be different
than the Jews, it's preferable
that you fast on the 9th also. So, the
best is to fast on the 9th
and the 10th.
But even if someone fasts on the 10th
only, scholars say it's fine. Some
scholars say that you can also fast on
the 10th and the 11th to be different
than the Jews.